vladimir putin putting on a propaganda
show for the russian people as he brings
more death and destruction to ukraine
the unhinged dictator holding a rally in
a moscow stadium boasting about the
success of his invasion of ukraine
despite a massive loss of russian troops
putin also claiming it was justified
this is what genocide is all about
it is precisely to save people from this
suffering from this genocide that is the
main reason for the convincing motive
and goal of the military operation that
we launched in the donbas and ukraine
mike tobin is in la vie ukraine with the
latest there mike
well judge the relative peace of the
western part of this country was
shattered this morning as the sirens
wailed and four cruise missiles slammed
down perilously close to nato's eastern
flank the tire the target of these
airstrikes was the leve state aircraft
repair which customizes uh mig-29s so
they could be used by the ukrainian air
force maxim kasich who's the regional
administrator of levi says six cruise
missiles were launched over the black
sea by long-range bombers two of them
were intercepted four of them made their
way to their target the ukrainian air
force says the russian x 555 with a
price tag around a million dollars a
piece it's a desperate situation down
south in the town of mariopol where the
donetsk regional drama theater was being
used as a bomb shelter it was clearly
marked that there were children inside
it was still hit by russian aircraft
anyway
as many as a thousand people were inside
on both the first floor and in the
basement we got reports yesterday that
some people got out uh today we are
hearing from a politician down there
that the rescuers who are attempting to
uh free the people trapped in the rubble
are being fired upon by the russian
forces and cannot even get to the
wreckage to get people out or determine
the extent of the casualties mariopol
itself has become an apo apocalyptic
scene with 80 percent of the housing
there destroyed the people there are
resorting to mass graves simply because
they cannot handle the logistics of how
many dead
they have on their hands the people in
that town are leaving but the
humanitarian corridors they say are not
holding together the people are
desperate enough that they are fleeing
under fire quite literally running for
their lives judge
mike thanks so much
all right guys you know the
juxtaposition of the mass graves and the
killing of children and the inability of
people you know to even wait in line
without getting in a breadline without
getting shot uh it it it's just amazing
so you've got
all we've heard about putin hiding now
he's out with about 200 000 people in
and around that stadium and you kind of
wonder is he copying zielinski now or
did he think he needed to show up his
support is his country does he need to
let them know they're in charge there
was the anniversary of the crimea
invasion so you have to hold a big rally
and it was a fake rally the bbc had a
team of reporters inside and said most
of these people were
public sector employees that were forced
to go there by their employer a bunch of
the younger people were told
they didn't even know where they were
going they were told we're going to send
you to a concert and we'll let you go to
the concert if you know you can have off
for the day so they went and they found
out it was a putin rally one guy gave a
quote to the bbc he said i'll be here
for a while then i'll leave i think most
people here don't support the war i
don't and the bbc said most people felt
ashamed and embarrassed to be there so i
do feel bad for the russian people it's
like having your father be a career
criminal
it's humiliating and there's nothing you
can do about it and now this guy's going
out there and he's acting like it's 1945
and just lying his way through a war
in 2022 you can't do that you can't lie
about a war in this day and age it's
just impossible and how humiliating must
it be
for vladimir putin to have to tell all
the people around him these are the lies
that we're going to tell and then you're
going to have to taste my food because
i'm so paranoid you all hate me i think
you're going to kill me
that is an insane way to run a country
he must be a complete psychopath to rule
a nation in this day and age like that
well anyone who says they're going to
demilitarize uh a a country
because of nazism when the president is
jewish i mean it's not so to be
prosperous but but um dagon i want to
ask you this when he was speaking to
that crowd he quoted the bible he talked
about russia prevailing and you know
against a nation without nazism and he
stirs up this russian nationalism does
this suggest that he's in all the way to
the end that there's no way he's he's
not stopping and that it's a fight to
the finish
uh the only way this ends quickly is if
something happens to putin like a brain
aneurysm i i'm not i'm not joking and
i'm not going to talk about you know
well i'm going to use the word
assassination but that's the only way
that it ends and by the way the since
the annexation of crimea the ruble has
fallen because of the sanctions it
hadn't really come back russians are
poor since then their visa restrictions
and there's it's there's less prosperity
in the country but you still their
fidelity
to putin particularly among older
russians has not completely been shaken
because russia since put putin took over
it was a kleptocracy after the fall of
the soviet union it was ruled by
criminals you get shot in the street and
so russia is in better shape than it was
and there is this deep nationalism and
and a
willingness to endure and suffer you
know starbucks closing is not a hardship
in russia in terms of and
i don't want to get
too off track but one of the the russian
people are in part cut off from
information because of our technology
grades google and apple they caved
to putin last fall
they
were wildly ignorant of what he was
capable of and they um google and apple
got threats from putin's of his strong
men and they took down
an app that was designed to get russians
to register protest votes against putin
that was backed by opposition leader
alexei navani apple started configuring
iphones that would you um to make it
easier to promote kremlin-backed social
media company companies and also in
in russia you still don't have access to
this apple security tool it's a feature
designed to make internet browsing
undetectable apple won't offer that to
russia so they are essentially doing
putin's bidding and again so much for
the freedom of these technology grades
all right greg one person who has gotten
outside of that is arnold schwarzenegger
i want you to take a listen never heard
of him ukraine did not start this war
neither did nationalists or nazis
those in power in the kremlin started
this war
this is not the russian people's war
this is an illegal war
your lives
your limps
your futures are being sacrificed for a
senseless war condemned by the entire
world
go ahead greg uh best work since conan i
think uh i'm not i'm actually not
kidding this is you know i thought it
was pretty impressive
it was very persuasive it was incredibly
well written
uh and it was also
we we've been talking about this idea of
face saving and status preservation and
that's what he did for nine minutes when
he was talking to the russians and
talking to putin because putin follows
him on twitter he has 22 uh uh people in
one of them so when you have to talk
when you're talking to this this country
with a deep history you have to talk
about
you're a great people i love you he was
so polite so polite and he also
referenced his own flaws dad's a nazi
whoops um he kind of he went overboard
on january 6th but he did that
not for us he did it for russia to say
hey look we have our problems too and
i'm gonna call out january 6 but i'm
going to call out this as well so i
thought it was very persuasive so i go
and i you know i text elena my wife
she's in warsaw i go hey what'd you
think of that and she said it was great
it was into her the thing that she loved
about it was it was polite and she said
it made her cry in a way but to see that
that how in a weird way naive we are to
think it it would actually matter and i
go like oh you mean you don't think it
would move the needle or have an impact
and she just responded with a number of
laughing emojis and a capitalized no
and i thought to myself i'd go like you
know what this kind of thing we believe
as americans it has an impact that's the
best celebrity video you're ever going
to get when you think about it but it's
like but
russia they didn't grow up with freedom
of speech they don't they don't have
that's a thing that's not in their blood
so
whether this has an impact on them and
and persuades them i don't know the
people it does persuade are already
there young people who have access to
the internet social media in this they
already get it but in terms of everybody
else i don't i don't know but i still
thought i mean i have friends of mine
who think it's going to have a big
impact
but the the russians who are to use your
phrase would you write say ashamed and
embarrassed they are all ashamed and
embarrassed and and they're so
pessimistic when i you know i go this is
great you're going greg it's
it's it's too late you know for our
country they're like so they're sickened
um all right jessica if the west is
serious about stopping putin
and you know his so-called stopping of
genocide in the ukraine and his
celebration of taking crimea how can
they do it
well it seems
that they are making pretty good headway
here i mean everything that you hear out
of this not out of putin's mouth but
everyone else's mouth so u.s
intelligence officials uk intelligence
officials the polls what you hear from
the ukrainians zalinsky and his team is
that they are holding russians at bay
they have lost thousands of people he
has committed war crimes those are huge
travesties but when you think back to
how petrified we were about that convoy
remember that was outside of kiev and it
was nine miles longer it was 13 miles
long and now it's nothing right we don't
hear about that anymore what happened in
mariopol which i hope that i pronounced
correctly huge travesty i'd love to see
it the greek prime minister he said
we're rebuilding that hospital because
that's where the largest amount of
greeks are in ukraine when you see the
three prime ministers coming from other
nato countries and sitting there with
zielinski in kiev that's important and
when i watched the putin's speech what i
saw was just a man alone he has no
allies to come and stand next to him
there were four or five countries right
who backed him up he couldn't even get
the chechnyan leader to show up to stand
there with him and he couldn't get
people from the former ussr
and
i've i don't want to say i feel good
about democracy's chances here but it
really does feel like it is the entire
world against this man and what we have
to do and why the rhetoric of a video
like what arnold schwarzenegger made i
think could matter is decoupling
nationalism for russians from putin is
the important rhetorical trick here
because he is not representing national
interests these are people who have been
oppressed from the get-go and we have to
turn the tide on that and every little
bit if someone sees that video and they
pass it to their moms and activate those
moms i mean the russian mothers have
played a hugely important role in
keeping russia on a good path and now
that they are getting the chance to
facetime their kids who have been sent
over to ukraine not knowing where
they're going i hope to see more of that
kind of activity but we need to you know
what i think decouple putin from the
money that's funding the war and when
you have sanctions are hugely effective
two-thirds of russia's economy is not
sanctioned jessica not any energy
transaction you know what goes and
that's on europe
the things that i think is important is
something that you mentioned and that is
with the we've got three nato leaders
who are with zielinski right now in kiev
if we were able to have those three nato
leaders it just more
leaders every day along with the
patriarch from the russian orthodox uh
uh
religious community from the greek
orthodox religious community stand there
with zielinski with all nato all the
religious leaders that would have a
profound effect on the world in terms of
this is diplomacy if you're going to
bomb us you're going to bomb the
churches and you're going to bomb the
leaders of nato we do then you're going
to get your nuclear war well we'll see i
don't know if what
anyway coming up president biden talking
tough about russia in a meeting with
china but will the commies actually
listen